we've gotten to know each other pretty
well it's started with you coming on the
show then you were kind enough to show
me a a spa a real Korean spa here in Los
Angeles and you took me through it we
were naked together you let me give you
a colonoscopy no we were we had this
great and was really fun and we had a
great experience and that culminated in
us then deciding let's go to Korea yeah
so we went to Korea shot and whole
episode there had all these amazing
adventures spent a lot of time with each
other and then the awkward thing is were
on the plane back home after just
knowing each other for such a long time
and you leaned over and you said by the
way Conan you're pronouncing my last
name wrong and I was like what what do
you mean like just today and you went no
it's been a couple of years and I was
horrified I'm so horrified because I had
been thinking I was being correct and
putting a little bit of a union yeah
yeah yeah but I was doing the right
thing I was it's just young and you had
never corrected me yet hundreds of hours
I just I felt bad bad like well you
can't stop someone from from from
mispronouncing your name like yes again
then you just sound like that guy that
like he's like actually it's Yun and
then you're like oh everybody's
embarrassed and it's a net loss so you
thought it was better to wait four years
and then tell me so that we could
discuss it on television I workup two
things
mime Conan oh yeah no I just was like I
was just uh I was just thought it's so
funny it never and I think you were just
very you're very polite but probably to
a fault I would yeah and that one was
just I I couldn't I couldn't you know my
cousin actually mispronounced is my last
name my blood cousin mispronounce is my
last name oh so I feel a lot better
actually yeah yeah my cousin Michael
song he's he he have use don't share the
last name he calls me Union and I've
caught him doing it the last couple of
times in the last couple of years which
shocks me because he's like old you hear
this newspapers like Steven Yeun does
this I'm like what was that it's like
it's like you can choke him with the
force I think he started doing that cuz
you though yeah that's how influential I
have people in your family now see a
community the way we pronounce it
probably would have been easier if you
just started pronouncing your name that
well that's sure that yeah yeah now
originally what was originally your
first name is that correct
yeah how does it works hyung yup so it's
my first name is hung up originally okay
and then they then they changed it to
Steven okay because because we met a
doctor and his name was Steven
[Applause]
dr. yeah yeah that's all yeah that's all
they have I was Charles until I saw
Schwarzenegger movie enough it was
predator you know
you